okay so we already discussed earlier and
i mentioned to you that a man was killed
in portland oregon over the weekend
and this as well as some of the other
events of the weekend
despite not stopping donald trump from
golfing did set him off
tweeting completely uncontrollably for
hours
in the middle of the night and these
really were
the rantings of a madman and they're
you know it's it's not normal for
anybody to behave this way on social
media it's not normal for
anybody to be tweeting this much on
social media
most people don't have this much time to
be spending so much time tweeting and
retweeting things on social media
and i mean listen when i see someone
tweeting at messages
at me so frequently i just mute them
immediately and we have the president
doing this
and each of these tweets we're going to
look at are so riddled with lies we
could analyze all of them in detail
i'm only going to do a couple many of
these are sort of illuminating or
informative in some way i think there's
something we can we can get from them
um so one of the questions that has been
coming up
is why isn't joe biden criticizing the
violence and unrest in the streets and
of course he has but donald didn't
really matter to donald trump donald
trump tweeting quote
when is slow joe biden going to critic
criticize the anarchists thugs and
agitators in
antifa when is he going remember antifa
hasn't killed anyone
when is he going to suggest bringing up
the national guard
in badly run and crime infested democrat
cities and states remember he can't lose
the crazy bernie
super liberal vote well biden did
actually do that denouncing and it's
trump who has refused to denounce
some of the individuals and some of the
violence that has actually taken place
over the last four days joe
joe biden put out a statement about this
and in that statement he said quote
i condemn this violence unequivocally
i condemn violence of every kind by
anyone
whether on the left or the right and i
challenge donald
trump to do the same well trump hasn't
it does not matter
if you find the political views of your
opponents
abhorrent any loss of life is a tragedy
today there is another family grieving
in america
and jill and i offer our deepest
condolences but it doesn't matter to
trump
it's the narrative that biden won't
denounce it and things will be even
crazier if biden is president
and it's working on a bunch of people
trump also had a two-tweet
rant about joe biden we'll go through
some of the lies here
joe biden is coming out of the basement
earlier than his hoped for
10 days because his people told him he
has no choice his poll numbers are
plunging now that's not true
there is a tightening in some areas but
biden's numbers aren't plunging
trump goes on going to pittsburgh where
i have helped industry to a record last
year that's a lie
and then back to his basement for an
extended period his problem is
interesting he must always be weak on
crime
because of the bernie sanders radical
left voter
what's amazing on this is that one of
the primary critiques from the bernie
left about biden
is his involvement in the 1990s crime
bill which even though it was almost 30
years ago
still is mentioned as biden being too
much like a republican
on supposed law and order and crime but
in any case you can't talk sense into
these people
trump going on if he loses them like
crooked hillary did he is
toast and many will vote for me because
of
trade bernie was good on trade joe
must always be weak on crime
so this is now you know the basement
stuff continues and the joe biden is
weak
stuff is is continuing but it's also
completely disconnected from what joe
biden is actually doing joe biden
actually
has been more visible lately joe biden
is going to be
speaking in a few places joe biden's rnc
speech
dnc speech rather compared to trump's
rnc speech was tethered to reality
unremarkable but completely reasonable
trump then going on to tweet
the only way you will stop the violence
in the high crime democrat-run cities
is through strength now remember
whatever violence is going on now
is going on now when trump is president
and trump insisting that to stop the
violence
that's happening during his presidency
you need to re-elect him
doesn't pass the sniff test but as i
talked about in the last segment
the chaos helps trump big picture
that's scary trump also retweeting a
bunch of different
fight videos believe it or not this is
the president of the united states
trump also tweeting attacks on different
people for example tweeting ted
wheeler the wacky radical left
do-nothing democrat mayor of portland
who has watched great death and
destruction of his city during his
tenure
thinks this lawless situation should go
on forever
wrong portland will never recover
with a fool for a mayor remember trump
is president now
if trump can stop the violence why
isn't trump stopping the violence or
saying he won't do it
until he's reelected very very
disturbing
that that is not raising a red flag with
tens of millions of trump voters
trump also tweeting law and order
in all capital letters multiple times
over the weekend
hundreds of tweets and retweets
outrageous behavior from a sitting
president of the united states
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app
and the browser plug-in let you give
each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.com slash pacman